tech giants will have to change the way
they do business in europe or
face fines of up to 10 of worldwide
turnover
the eu's draft rules are designed to
rein in the power of the american
companies and bring order
to chaos facebook's mark zuckerberg and
other tech bosses control troves of data
and platforms
on which thousands of companies and
millions of europeans rely on
let's have a listen into what the
competition commissioner margaret
vestager had to say a short while ago
about the digital services
and digital markets act two proposals
they serve one purpose to make sure that
we
as users as customers businesses
have access to a wide choice of safe
products and services
online just as well as we do in the
physical world
and that all businesses operating in
europe that can be big ones that can be
small
small ones that they can freely and
fairly competes
online just as they do offline because
this is one world brussels sees the
power of google
amazon and facebook as a threat to
competition and democracy
here's more on the rules for doing
business in the block's 27 countries
the european commission used an advant
calendar
to announce its updated digital rules
a long-awaited chocolate treat for many
people
some say this new legislation could
change the internet as we know it
and limit at least in some parts the
enormous power of tech giants
that influence so much of our daily
lives
we search with google online we buy
christmas presents on amazon
we share our latest holiday snaps with
our friends on facebook
or instagram or whatsapp that both
belong to social media giant facebook
a few tech giants dominate the internet
and dictate its rules
studies show for example that google's
online shopping search engine
is still disadvantaging rivals despite
the regulatory crackdown
three years ago or let's take a look at
youtube
owned by google companies like youtube
collect data from users
this information then feeds algorithms
that decide
which ads and which content we see
online
it is not transparent how it works the
eos legal framework for the internet is
20 years old
when the world wide web was completely
different
it is time for an update but it could
take years to be implemented
as different eu institutions
have to agree on a common line
in the meantime member of the european
parliament timothy joins us thanks for
being on dw
how will this change the internet is it
going to
tackle fake news and hate speech and
things like that
yes it will so we will have clear rules
uh rules specif specifies specifying
sorry
the irresponsibilities of platforms
especially when it comes to how
platforms moderate
content so at the moment the roots are
not clear
so platforms did not have legal
certainty
and the fundamental fundamental rates of
users were not guaranteed so
we now have the chance to set a very
clear
rule book with the rules proposed today
by the commission
and i think that they will have the
potential to change the internet yes
and and this punishment of 10 or up to
10
of worldwide turnover i mean it sounds
huge but will it be enough to
to change the way these guys do business
and make sure that
hate speech and fake news isn't uh
continue to be spread
so i think it does not only sound huge
but it is really huge so if you compare
it to the
general data protection rules gdpr which
entered the defaults a few years ago
we see that there is a fine third
percent
of the the turnover so
this 10 fine is way
more and we see that companies
are of course adhering
so they are following the rules in the
gdpr so i think
that this fine really is a huge
and can yeah really change the behavior
of big platforms
what about competition what's it going
to do to competition do you think
the whole proposal is uh so
well we we need to go step back so we
have two proposals on the table the one
is the
dsa the digital services act which is uh
tailored to deal with content on
platforms
roughly and we have the dma which
focuses on the
competition site what we're seeing
the market act yes sorry yes the digital
market act
and what we're seeing at the moment is
that uh the competition
files launched by the commission they
take years
and in the end the fines are not very
huge compared
to what the platforms earned why
they were breaching competition laws so
we need a new tool and this tool is
presented in the dma
with the black white and graylist
approach
the the dma really takes uh focuses
on practices by platforms which prove
which have proven that they are harmful
to the competition
when are we going to see all of this
because i know it's only a legal
framework
it's a proposal by the commission and
other eu institutions including the
european parliament
will have to find a common line before
this all becomes reality
so if if you take the the press
conference which was delayed today by
roughly two hours this is maybe an
indicator
so this will take long so we are not
talking about
one or two years uh i hope that we will
finish the the legislation on the dsa
and the dma
within this mandate so um there are many
challenges ahead
and so i i'm completely motivated and
the parliament sent a strong signal to
the commission a few
weeks ago when we adopted our initiative
reports on the dsa and ema
but in the end there will be a tough
fight at least that's what i predict
between the parliament and the council
so this will
take years then weeks i hope the rest of
brussels
is just as motivated as you timo member
of the european parliament thank you
very much for joining us tonight
thank you very much bye and for more i'm
joined now by christy platson from dw
business
christy this is not the first time the
eu is trying to control the way big tech
companies are operating
what'll be different this time
well what we've seen in recent years is
essentially the european commission
chasing after these companies and
specific behaviors with targeted
lawsuits
and big tech has frankly been relatively
successful at either getting these
verdicts
overturned if they didn't favor them or
in just avoiding paying the fines that
they were ordered to pay
so what would be really different in
this case is we're looking at bottom-up
legislation that would really set a
framework
for how these companies are allowed to
behave and the commission really wants
to get to the heart of problems like the
spread of disinformation
hate speech online and make these
companies really take up more
responsibility
for these areas right and when you say a
bottom-up
regulation was there any input from tech
companies as
they they'll be affected by it yeah
great question well
as with any eu legislation there's
always a phase in which
the public and other stakeholders are
allowed to provide feedback about
about the idea and of course the
companies had something to say
google thinks it's a bad idea naturally
saying that this is going to drive up
prices for users their logic there is
that if they're forced to pay hefty
fines or to
drop out of uh projects in which they've
invested heavily
that they're going to have to pass those
costs on to their advertising prices
they also said that they actually
welcome clarity about what to do about
hate speech but that companies need to
be given enough time to respond to
instances
of hate speech before being held
financially liable
and then there was apple who said that
the uh the legislation is too wide
sweeping
and that a company that makes tech
devices like they do shouldn't be
handled the same way that a social media
giant like facebook should be
okay so no euphoria there just yet and
of course the eu's currently the
framework as we just heard for the
internet is 20 years old
and it could take years to implement
this the new rules right now
we know that technology won't wait for
that will they
yeah no i'm not thinking it will and
it's a great question i think uh that
it's
going to be hard to say right now
whether this legislation will be able to
react in time
like you said it's going to be taking
years
before negotiations are done and before
this can pass and a lot of the
smaller and mid-sized digital companies
that are actually
supposed to be protected by these laws
have complained that they'll be put out
of business before
they uh they even go through on the
other hand
commissioner vessiger has really staked
her legacy on taking
reigning in big tech so i think that
it's really going to come down to who
has the greater influence here uh the
commission
or big tech all right well we'll find
out soon enough dws christy platson
there from dw business thank you so much
thanks
you